If the first blockade failed,
why should we expect the second blockade
to succeed? What's changed here?
The West is leading
Ukraine down the primrose path
the Israelis
are executing a genocide in Gaza.
It's not China's fault
that it wants to be powerful.
So if you get into trouble
and you dial 911,
there's nobody at the other end.
Hi, this is John Mearsheimer.
Today is August 17th, 2026,
and today is the day that the Memorandum
of understanding that was signed by Iran
and the United States on June
17th expires.
The original memorandum of understanding
called
for 60 days of negotiation,
and it was assumed
that at the end of those 60 days,
there would be an agreement.
And at that point the
the memorandum would expire.
Well, 60 days have gone by
and there's obviously been no agreement,
but the memorandum of understanding
has definitely expired,
and there's no effort
being made to extend it.
So the question is,
where are we today in the absence
of the memorandum of understanding?
And it seems quite clear
that what has happened
is that the United States has decided
that it's going to depend on its naval
blockade of Iran to achieve its goals.
So what I'd like to do
today is just talk about
what a naval blockade today
is likely to be able to achieve
for the United States,
given that we don't have any prospect of
a new memorandum of understanding,
what can blockade do
for the United States?
Is it a viable alternative
for getting our way?
Now, the best way to start is just talk
about what our goals are,
and then talk about what
Iran's goals are.
And you want to remember that
when we talk about Iran's goals,
we want to talk about the United States
thwarting Iran's goals.
So the United States, in a very important
way, has two sets of goals here.
One is to cheat, to achieve its own goals,
and number two,
to thwart Iran from achieving its goals.
So let me start by talking
about what America's goals are
and then look at Iran's goals.
And then we can talk about
how well suited blockade is at this point
in time for us, the United States,
achieving its goals.
When the war started back on February
28th of this year,
the United States had four goals.
Number one was regime change.
Number two was to put an end
to Iran's nuclear enrichment capability.
Number three was to put an end
to Iran's long range missile capability.
And number four
was to end Iranian support
for the Houthis, Hezbollah and Hamas.
Those were the Big Four goals.
The United States, of course,
has achieved none of those goals.
None of them have been achieved.
And there is no chance that
any of the four are going to be achieved.
So the question
we then have to ask ourselves is,
what are America's
goals at this point in time?
And Vice President Vance said last week
very clearly that we have two goals.
He said that
the first and most important goal
is to open the strait.
He said the second goal
is to get a nuclear deal.
This is actually quite remarkable
because when we went into the war,
what mattered more than anything else
was the nuclear issue.
And of course, the strait was opened on
February 27th.
So the whole idea of opening
the strait was not even on the table
right before the war started.
It was the nuclear issue
that really mattered.
So here's Vice President Vance
saying that our principal goal is
to open the strait, and our secondary
goal is to get a nuclear deal.
By the way, President Trump's
spokesperson has said that
as far as President Trump is concerned,
those two goals are co-equal.
So he has a slightly different view
of things than Vice President Vance does.
But nevertheless,
you can see how important it is
for us to open the strait
as soon as possible.
And that is obviously
for economic reasons.
Now we want to do a switch gears,
and we want to talk about what
Iran's goals are.
And you want to keep in mind
what the United States wants to do
is make sure that Iran does not achieve
any of its goals,
if that's possible,
or all of its goals are denied.
No, let me put it differently,
that we want to make sure that Iran
doesn't achieve
all its all of its goals. And
in the best case, to
minimize the number of goals
that Iran achieves.
Okay,
the Iranians do want to open the strait.
There's no question about that.
Like us,
they want to open the strait like us.
They understand it's in their economic
interest to open the strait.
But the Iranians say that they won't
open the strait unless the United States
meets a number of other demands,
not through negotiation, but right away.
In other words,
the Iranians say we'll open the strait
if you agree to lift
all sanctions on Iran,
if you agree to freeze
all of unfreeze all of our frozen assets,
if you agree to pay reparations,
if you agree that we control the strait,
if you agree that we can collect fees,
if you agree to remove
American military
forces from the Gulf region.
These are the demands
that the Iranians have.
And the Iranians are saying
the United States has to meet
all those demands
before they will open the strait.
Now, obviously,
the United States is not interested
in excepting all of those demands,
but the Iranians have made it clear
that the United States has no choice.
What we want to do is minimize the number
of demands that we are forced to accept.
The Iranians say
there will be no minimization.
You have to accept all of those demands
before we will agree to open the straight.
And again,
you want to remember that America's
principal goal is to open the strait. So
the question is
how can we achieve our goals?
And.
Blockade is the strategy of the day.
But I want to say a few words
about what our strategy
has been in the entire war,
so that we can put
where we are today
with blockade into a broader context.
As you remember,
the war started on February 28th,
and we started with a major strategic
bombing campaign.
An air campaign that lasted for 40 days
went from February 20th 8th to April 8th.
Then there was a cease fire on April 8th.
There were some negotiations
that went nowhere.
And then on April 13th, the United States
moved to a naval blockade.
So you see,
this is the first time we tried blockade.
And the blockade that is now in place
is the second instance of a blockade.
So we went from an air war in the first
40 days of the war up till April 8th.
Then on April 13th,
we moved to the first blockade.
And that first blockade lasted from April
13th up until June
17th, when the memorandum of understanding
was signed.
So that's the way of saying
that the first blockade lasted
about two plus months and it did not work.
We ended up signing a memorandum
of understanding on June 17th.
And that MOU, of course, is
what put an end to the blockade,
the first blockade.
But that memorandum of understanding
was extremely favorable to the Iranians.
It was a memorandum of understanding
that the United States did not like,
because the United States understood
it was a surrender document,
but nevertheless,
the United States signed it
and the United States signed it
because the blockade did not work.
And before that, the air war did not work.
Okay, then what happens in early July
is that the United States and Iran
get involved in a tit for tat strategy.
This starts on July 7th
and it lasts until about July 31st.
And it basically involves
the United States and Iran engaging
in a limited air war
where they bomb specific
targets on each side.
In other words, the United States bombs
targets in Iran and the Iranians bomb
targets in Kuwait, Saudi Arabia
and so forth and so on.
And this last, again
from July 7th to July 31st,
then the tit for tat campaign
comes to an end.
And what happens is the United States
moves to the second blockade.
The second blockade
actually starts on July 14th,
which is in the middle of the tit
for tat campaign.
So there's a period there
where you have the tit
for tat campaign taking place
and you have the second blockade.
But as I said before, on July 31st,
the tit for tat campaign comes to an end.
The United States
has basically had enough.
So all that's left is the blockade,
the second blockade.
And that's where we are today.
Now, the question we have to ask ourselves
is, given that the memorandum
of understanding has expired
and there's no prospect
of a new memorandum of understanding.
And given
that we've given up on tit for tat,
given up on a major bombing campaign,
given that there's not going to be a land
option.
The question is, what will blockade do
for the United States
in terms of achieving its objectives?
Now, we know that the first blockade
didn't work.
So the question is,
what about this second blockade?
Now, it's important to start by saying
that at the end of last week,
the Secretary of the Treasury,
Scott Besson, said that this week,
starting today,
we are going to inflict unprecedented
economic hurt
on the Iranian economy.
So, in effect, what he was saying
is that in addition to the blockade
and this naval blockade is designed
to inflict economic hurt
on the Iranian economy,
we're going to do something special
this week, and we're going to deliver
unprecedented economic hurt. Now,
let's
evaluate
how well this is all likely to work.
First of all, it's hard to believe
that there's more economic hurt
that we can inflict on Iran.
We've really maxed out at this point.
What is the United States
going to do to damage further
the Iranian economy
that it hasn't already done?
Besson hasn't told us
he's made this vague claim,
but he hasn't told us how this process
works.
I would argue that this virtually nothing
the United States can do to create
unprecedented economic hurt.
So this brings us
back to the question of the blockade.
What is the likelihood that this blockade
is going to produce a favorable outcome
for the United States?
In other words, what is the likelihood
that this blockade is going
to allow us to achieve our own goals
and limit
the number of goals that Iran has
that it can achieve?
Well, the first point you want to keep in
mind is that the first blockade failed.
And if the first blockade failed,
why should we expect the second blockade
to succeed?
What's changed here?
And by the way, you want to remember
that the first blockade, as I said, lasted
a little over two months,
went from April 13th to June 17th.
So a little over two months
and it didn't work again.
We signed the memorandum of understanding,
which was basically a surrender document.
Well, the present blockade has gone on
since July 14th.
It's a little over one month,
so we haven't even reached
the two month period here.
And you want to keep in mind,
as I talk here, that blockades
only work over a long period of time,
almost everybody agrees
that blockades do not produce
instant results.
So for this blockade to work,
it's going to have to be in place for
a long period of time.
We're not going to get instant results.
Now, there are very good reasons
to think that we, the United States,
are in a worse position today
in terms of implementing
this blockade than we were when we started
the first blockade on April 13th.
Now, why is that the case?
One reason is the state of the US Navy.
It's quite clear that the US Navy
is suffering in significant ways
from the wear and tear of being deployed
to the Gulf for a long period of time.
And we see this with the case of the USS
Abraham Lincoln.
This is the large aircraft carrier
where there has been
huge dissatisfaction
among the crew members
because of the demands
of this naval campaign against Iran.
The United States has been forced
to deploy
ships like this
carrier, the Lincoln and destroyers,
and other ships as well,
for extended periods of time in the area
or in the waters around Iran.
And those troops on
these ships
have not been getting proper food,
and they have not
been in very good living conditions,
and all sorts of trouble
has broken out on the Lincoln.
There's evidence that some of the sailors
were thinking about
jumping off the side of the carrier.
There's evidence that fights had been
breaking out and so forth and so on.
So actually what's happened is that the
the Lincoln has been taken off station
and it's
being replaced by another carrier
by the USS George Washington.
Now, it's very important to emphasize
that it's not only the Lincoln
that is suffering from these problems,
destroyers and other ships
that have been deployed for extended
periods of time are also having all sorts
of linguistic problems.
So my point here is
that for purposes of implementing
a protracted blockade and blockades,
by definition of protracted,
the US Navy is in terrible shape
to accomplish that mission.
There's just been so much wear and tear
on the US Navy that it's not clear
that it can keep in place a successful
blockade for many more months.
There's an additional additional issue
at play here,
and that is that
the Navy, at this point in
time is small enough
that it is only capable of focusing
on one theater of operations
at a time, in a major way.
And what this means is that
because we are focusing
laser like on the Middle East
or on the Persian Gulf or on Iran,
what we are doing
is weakening ourselves in East Asia.
And you want to remember that
in East Asia, where the United States
is interested in containing China,
naval forces matter greatly.
Naval and air forces matter
much more than land forces in East Asia.
When you talk about containing China.
But what's happening here
is that the United States is being forced
to pull forces out of East Asia
and send them to the Persian Gulf.
And this is true
with regard to naval forces.
As I said before, given the consequences
of the logistical problems
that the Abraham Lincoln
faces, it's being taken off station
and it's being replaced,
as I said, by the US as George Washington.
The question
you want to ask yourself is, where is
the George Washington coming from?
And the fact is, it's coming from East
Asia.
It's normally stationed in Japan.
This means there's going to be no aircraft
carrier in East Asia.
This is not good
for a strategic point of view.
When you think about containing China.
So not only is the wear and tear on the US
Navy limiting its overall capabilities,
the focus on Iran
keeping a blockade on
Iran is also weakening America's position
in East Asia vis a vis
its most important threat, which is China.
There are additional problems
with the blockade.
One is that as long as we keep
the blockade on and the Iranians
keep the blockade
on, what we are doing is greatly limiting
the amount of oil
that comes out of the Persian Gulf,
because both sides are, in effect,
blockading the Strait of Hormuz.
This means that there's less oil to appear
on global or in global markets.
Furthermore,
because there has been a huge conflict
between the Houthis and the Saudis,
and the Houthis
have basically shut off the Bab El
Mondavi Strait, which is where Saudi oil
comes out of the Red sea.
Saudi oil is now not only coming out
of the
Persian Gulf through the Strait of Hormuz.
It's not coming
out of the Red sea through El Mundo.
And it is imperative
to have lots of Saudi oil
on our in global markets.
But that's no longer the case.
This is not to deny,
of course, that some ships do get through
either the Strait of Hormuz
or the Bab El Mundo Strait.
Some sortie ships do, but not many.
So the amount of Saudi oil that was coming
out of the Gulf on February 27th
has been greatly reduced,
and this is a huge problem
for the international economy.
So there are all sorts of economic
incentives to open the strait.
I might also note that
if you look at the Strategic Petroleum
Reserve in the United States
and the Strategic Petroleum Reserve
in other countries, it's quite clear
that we have significantly drawn down
those reserves to make up for the fact
that so much oil is now not coming
out of the Gulf.
And the question is,
how long can we depend on
taking all out of those strategic
petroleum reserve in places
like the United States
to deal with this problem of,
of of
missing or coming out of the Persian
Gulf.
Now, another
very important dimension to this
is that if you look at what's happened
inside of Iran,
the hardliners are now in control
and the hard liners are not interested
in reaching any kind of accommodation
with the United States.
They are interested in driving a hard
bargain.
They interest they are interested
in telling the United States
it has to meet all of Iran's demands,
which I described before.
Before Iran will agree to open
the Strait of Hormuz.
And in addition to that, these hardliners
who are in charge inside of Iran,
or making it perfectly clear
that they want to
initiate military action
against the United States
and its allies in the Persian Gulf.
They believe that the best defense
is a good offense.
So if you look at the hardliners
who are now in control in Iran,
they are bent on causing
the United States more trouble than ever.
They are interested
in taking the initiative.
They are interested in being proactive.
So the United States now
faces a more dangerous adversary in Iran.
In addition
to the fact that the economic situation
is deteriorating for the reasons
I just described, and in addition
to the fact that the US
Navy is in bad shape
for purposes of implementing
a protracted naval blockade of Iran.
So the situation does not look good
at all.
Now, one might say, okay,
you've convinced me
that the blockade is not likely to work,
but maybe with the United States can do
here is go back to a tit
for tit for tat strategy.
Or maybe the United States can go back
to a major bombing campaign
like we saw in the first 40 days.
In other words,
we do have an escalation option.
But this is not true.
We don't have an escalation option.
In fact, we don't even want to go back
to a tit for tat strategy.
And there are basically three reasons
for that.
One is we have a significant shortage
of munitions.
And the last thing we want to do
is get involved in a tit for tat campaign
where we have to use up
even more of those precious munitions.
Furthermore, our Gulf allies
have zero interest in seeing the war start
back up again because they understand full
well that they will be targeted.
The Iranians have made that clear.
And of course, in the past the Iranians
have targeted our Gulf allies.
So our Gulf allies are saying
no more escalation.
And then finally,
there's the economic consequences.
At this point in time,
President Trump cannot afford
to restart the 40 day bombing campaign
or even engage in a tit for tat campaign.
He's got to open the strait.
That's why Vice President Vance said,
our principal goal is to open the strait.
We have to open that straight
for economic reasons.
So tit for tat is not even a viable option
for the United States,
much less starting the 40 day campaign.
And to drive that point home.
Let me tell you a story that shows you
how little interest
we have, even in escalating
to a tit for tat campaign.
As I said before, the tit for tat campaign
started on July 7th
and it lasted until July 31st.
Remember we had first
the strategic bombing campaign.
Then we had the first naval blockade
and we had the tit for tat campaign.
It started on July 7th.
Now why did it start?
How did the
how did the tit for tat campaign begin
on July 6th,
the Iranians attacked three
cargo vessels
that were trying to come out of the Strait
of Hormuz through the Omani Channel.
That was the channel
that's close to Amman that
the United States,
in effect, helped control.
The Iranians made it clear to us
that that was unacceptable.
No ships coming out of the Gulf
could go through
the Omani channel, said the Iranians.
Well, on July 6th, there were three ships
coming through the Omani channel
in the Strait of Hormuz,
and the Iranians opened
fire on all three of those ships.
This is July 6th.
The next day,
the United States started the tit
for tat campaign
by attacking targets inside of Iran.
The Iranians, of course, retaliated.
We retaliated and so forth and so on.
And this tit for tat campaign lasted
from the 7th of July to the 31st of July.
The key point that I want to make here
is what started it was that
the Iranians attacked cargo ships
going through the Strait of Hormuz,
and the United States said
that is categorically unacceptable.
And therefore
we went to the tit for tat campaign.
Well,
if you look at what's happening today,
the Iranians are attacking
cargo ships in the Strait
of Hormuz on an almost daily basis.
They make no bones about it.
And the question you want to ask yourself
is, what is the United States doing?
Is the United States retaliating?
Is the United States shown any interest
in going back to a tip for tat strategy?
The answer is no.
And the reason is that the United States
has zero
interest
in escalating to a tit for tat strategy.
So what we have
here is a very interesting situation.
If you think about it, if escalation
does take place in the Gulf, it's
not the United States
that is likely to initiate
that escalation.
It is the Iranians who are likely
to initiate that escalation,
because the leadership in Iran
very clearly now is interested in playing
hardball with the United States
from a military perspective.
As I said before, from
an Iranian point of view, they believe
that the best defense is a good offense,
so they are willing to escalate
because they believe
that the United States will not retaliate.
Now, it is possible
the United States will retaliate
at some point,
but that will not solve our problem.
So you see, what's happened here
is that over time,
the United States has failed
to achieve any of its objectives,
whether we're talking about the four
big objectives that had started the war
with or opening the strait
or getting a nuclear deal,
which are its two objectives today.
And at the same time, it's in a situation
where it looks like it has little choice
but to cave in to Iran's major demands,
because the United States has no strategy,
it has no military option
for achieving its goals
and preventing Iran from gaining
its goals.
It's been forced into a situation
where it has to rely on blockade.
And as I said before, blockade didn't work
the first time, and there's no reason
to think it's going to work this time,
because the situation
for the United States,
in terms of implementing a blockade
now is worse than it was between April
13th and June 17th.
And if you think about it,
what's happened here
is that the Iranians have really turned
the table tables in the sense
that the Iranians are now
the party in this conflict
that is most likely to cause escalation
in the beginning, that obviously
looked like the United States.
It looked in the very beginning,
like the United States held all the cards.
But as this conflict has worn on,
and as we've come to understand
here on August 17th,
we have no military option.
Escalation would be disastrous for us.
And if anything, it's the Iranians
who believe
they have a military option
and they believe they can escalate.
All of this is to say that it's hard
to see how the United States can achieve
even a limited victory
in this conflict with Iran.
It looks to me here on August 17th,
like the United States has little choice
but to surrender
to virtually all of Iran's demands
if it hopes to open the strait
and avoid an economic catastrophe.
That concludes my video for today.
Thank you all for listening,
and I look forward
to the next time that we talk.